está genial que creo que ya muchos de
ustedes ya los conozco porque estoy
facilitando con ustedes allá afuera qué
es lo que hago ayuda organizaciones a
tomar decisiones de forma acelerada y
para que le tomen de esa forma no los
trato como empresas los trato como
organismos vivientes donde cada una de
estas agentes o personas sus células
tiene acceso a información y la pone al
servicio del sistema al servicio del
todo y eso es lo que hicimos el día de
hoy ante una convocatoria la
convocatoria que es que futuro te
inspira cada uno de nosotros tiene un
futuro en su mente que le inspira y lo
que hicimos fue ponerlo en servicio a
los demás
cada uno llegó de forma voluntaria y
puso en un post-it a aquella cosa que no
hacía soñar está bien padre esto porque
no solamente se trata de lo que tenemos
en la cabeza sino como como personas nos
podemos organizar hace un bien mayor qué
es lo que vemos ahí somos todos hablando
al mismo tiempo sin interrumpir nos y lo
más importante es que se vio la el
voluntariado que es un voluntario es
aquella persona que tiene pasión por un
tema y compromiso porque ese tema se
lleva a cabo una vez que tenemos toda
ésta
colectiva aquí lo que hicimos fue
alinearla y aquí emergieron patrones que
son las temáticas que a este grupo le
son relevantes y son 11 si bien no vamos
a profundizar en estas 11 hay cuatro que
tuvieron mayor participación que les
quiero apuntar esta parte empieza a
pagar porque se van a ver reflejados
ustedes mismos allí acerca de la
naturaleza y sostenibilidad de hecho
acabamos de tener un speaker super cool
que nos habla acerca de ese este
movimiento que estamos haciendo por el
aire limpio cosas como más acción hacia
la orden hacia la estabilidad
sostenibilidad verde sustentable
movilidad sustentable conciencia
conocimiento otro tópico que emergió es
igualdad y respeto tuve una conversación
con una persona muy valiosa que hablaba
acerca de normalizar lo inusual acerca
de ayudarnos entre todos más calidad
humana más empatía otro tópico que
emergió es acerca de nuestro propósito
como personas mis metas mis sueños
oportunidades ser que queramos ser y por
último familia y amor amor con mi pareja
es unión unidad respeto la ilusión por
la familia esto habla de valores que
tenemos nosotros
grupo antes de inteligencia colectiva
que hemos generado es una convocatoria
que va más allá de nosotros aquí tienen
una herramienta porque no solamente se
trata lo que traemos en la cabeza sino
cómo nos organizamos todos para un bien
mayor muchas gracias
[Aplausos]